our next speaker today is cecily
morrison
um and i say today and not this morning
because cecily is based in cambridge
in the uk uh cecily is one of our
researchers
in our lab uh in in cambridge
and she leads a lot of our work around
accessibility among other things
uh and today cecily's going to be
talking to us about rethinking the
accessibility research problems that we
tackle
the floor is yours thanks very much can
i just check that i can be heard
yeah we hear you loud and clear great um
yes well it's good evening for me good
morning good
good afternoon for those of you
depending on where you are
and i'm going to be talking about what
does access mean so rethinking
accessibility research problems that we
tackle
now in my day job with my day hat on i'm
a principal researcher at microsoft
research
in cambridge and i led the team to
create a code jumper which is a physical
programming language
for teaching basic computation and basic
coding skills to children ages 7 to 11
regardless of their level of vision um
however today i'm here on in quite a
different hat i'm here
as a parent and specifically the parent
of a blind child
um so i have some pictures on my screen
the first one is a young blind girl
who's learning to code she's learning
about selection statements using code
jumper
and on the right hand side this is my
parent role i'm taking my three-year-old
son his massive cane and of course his
musical octopus
um off to london and what i'd really
like to do today
um is to try to bring some of those
experiences that i've had as a parent of
a disabled child
and reflect on how they've really
shifted my view on how i do my own
research and what research problems i
think
um really need tackling
i'd like to start with a story of the
first experience i had as a research
participant as opposed to a researcher
who which i'd already been for many
years
and in the the picture that you see
there that's me with my
um four-month-old baby uh he's sitting
in my lap he's reaching out and touching
my chin
and i think like like every mother i was
completely besotted with my child
totally high on the smiles he smiled all
the time and i really didn't care that
he was born without eyes
but i was determined that while his life
might be different that he should have
no
disadvantage because he was born totally
blind
so as a researcher and that's sort of my
inclination to know things
i just read everything i could find when
he was little blog posts research
articles i even snuck into the
university library to access things that
were only in print
and when i found a research study that
was focused on determining the best ways
to support development and blind babies
it was run by the center for development
for blind children in the uk
i signed up straight away
we had our first research visit when my
son was nine months old
and he's as he is in this picture you
see on the screen he's sitting in the
garden enjoying the sun with his sensory
toys
and he's smiling something that he has
done pretty much his whole life
so the researcher came she was also a
young mother she was very kind she
understood
about babies and the things that kind of
they do and don't do
um but besides her being very nice
things didn't go very well at all
um ronan just decided he didn't want to
participate and he did
nothing that she asked him for she was
with us for nearly two hours
um but we didn't really manage very much
but i have to say as this hours were
going past i was getting really confused
by what we were being asked to do and
all these kind of exercises like taking
a block out of a cup
and i was thinking why does that matter
but more importantly i was like
why would you do that with a blind child
this is a
small plastic cup dull wood block inside
it's completely uninteresting in my
experience that i'd had with my baby to
that point
and i suggested that perhaps you should
put a big marble in a metal cup i mean
it looked more or less the same exercise
to me and it would be much more
motivating a nicer sound
and she said to me well the measures are
standardized and they really couldn't be
changed because these specific exercises
have been normed against normally
developing sighted children
um so as a result after those two hours
we left without being marked as being
incapable of doing
any developmental exercise whatsoever
and i have to say i was a bit flummoxed
and i was pondering for a very long time
what could researchers possibly learn
about blind development if they were not
even
interested what motivates a blind child
to engage
and then i was thinking well my baby's
not even a year old and he's already
being expected to act
like a sighted child and he's going to
be judged accordingly and
this research is going to guide me in
how i'm going to raise my blind child
so i followed up with a clinical team
running the study and asked well
you know what are the kinds of things
that they recommend to get this
development
and i was told that well they had a
really strong correlation between
meeting milestones and development
but they really didn't know about which
how
activities could be adapted they weren't
entirely clear on the mechanisms that
underlie these tests that needed to be
stimulated
um so at the time i was thinking
well i now feel very judged my child has
been marked as being incapable of doing
anything
but also completely directionless um
there's no way forward so as a result
we've actually never participated in any
research again despite
obviously being as a researcher someone
very committed to research
i did however make up lots and lots of
engaging activities about taking lids on
and off containers putting things inside
in hope that somehow
these developmental milestones and this
idea of putting something in a cup
would work and i'll just share with you
a video of the kind of things that
many parents like me uh get on with
[Music]
give them on the way
okay good there you're ready
[Music]
lid on
lid off
[Music]
so i often think about this and many
other research projects that i've i've
come across
and chosen not to participate in as
doomsday research
and while i've simplified this example a
little bit to keep the time the end
result is that there's a lot of research
out there that tell the world there's a
big problem
but not really give a direction or an
answer to it and it's really etched
indelibly in my mind that incredibly
negative experience
um a number of questions that really
have influenced the way i
consider the research that i would like
to do
so i think that the first one is should
methodological sadness overpower the
participant experience in research
and i think a lot when we're dealing
with disability it's really easy for us
to
to choose one um over the other and
really should we be doing research that
has no
no value to the participants in this
case as
a parent there was really no value to me
in in what i could do
and should we be taking responsibility
as researchers to ensure we don't burn
out
a community of participants the
communities are small
everybody wants to move forward but how
do we make that work well
so we can talk about the nodes but i
think always more interesting is to talk
about
what can we what can we learn what could
we have what can we do
and so how can we innovate um new ways
of knowing about
unique populations um these standardized
ways which is
the typical way at least in the uk i
think don't really fit the bill
but you know as a parent i have many
gigabytes of videos in my child's first
three years could we have had a richer
data by using parent collected data
inference techniques could we learn from
parents about how their blind babies
respond and learn best could we have
provided ways to help parents better
access examples of other babies like
theirs
when no such thing as normal exists
so i think doomsday research is really
frustrating to parents to participants
um but it also really shapes the whole
system in which disabled children are
educated
the children in the uk and i think
there's something very similar in the us
have specialized plans that give them
legal access to an equal education
these plans lay out what provision must
be paid for and are vouched by
professionals in the fields occupational
therapists
teach the visually impaired speech and
language therapists to name a few
and at least children with sensory needs
these plans tend to be uh
pretty hefty in their in their in their
budget
so every year when we request things for
our son we hear
there's no evidence for that and i think
to give an example we we requested this
year a
type of speech therapy which is tactile
as most speech therapy is
visual in fact all other forms of speech
that are visual
and also happens to be the most
expensive one and we're then told
there's no evidence for effectiveness of
this particular
therapy in children and i said to them
well
are there blind children represented in
that database so the evidence is based
on
are there any studies that include blind
children are there any case studies that
include blind children
and the answer is either no or we don't
know
but needless to say having fought with
them and got it most parents in the end
simply end up backing down and i think
we as researchers
are continuing to contribute to a
culture of norming through our research
measures that we choose
through the way that we formulate our
cohorts we might argue that this norman
gives our research validity indeed
it certainly gives it internal validity
but it also validates
the ability as being different from a
norm rather than being unique
and i think certainly in the in the
blindness space with with
children they're very very diverse
group of people there's the low
incidence there's not very many of them
they're fairly high need
and they're very very different so it's
very difficult to think about what kind
of normal curve depiction of any kind of
evidence
you would want and i would say in our
experience as parents this culture
of norming is perhaps the most effective
blocker for children with disabilities
getting the education that they need
so even if that education is accessible
if you can't get it
you haven't gotten very far so what can
we as researchers offer
as alternative ways of knowing what can
be used that can be used in allocating
resources that don't pin parents into a
numbers game that most parents simply
don't
understand so this system
challenge is perhaps been our biggest
challenge as parents and we also
struggle very much with with social
inclusion and education so even if
what we do adapt is adaptable it's often
not
the child is removed from the the
mainstream setting that they're in
and it's very hard to support um
participation
but that said let's say that we can
solve those two
pretty big challenges um how do we
consider accessibility when we have
really highly diverse
needs and again i i speak for my my
position as a parent of a particular
child not not for the whole community
but i know that many parents have this
similar experience
that for we struggle with the systems
but actually access to the curriculum
tends to work a bit better so machines
are in place to produce braillers
produce braille content they're really
highly paid teachers to hand produce
graphs
and you know as someone who likes
efficient things i mean there are
lots of inefficiencies in this system
it's a very expensive system
but really the number of pupils is just
not big enough i think to really drive
change and it's really hard to get
even really useful innovations into that
pipeline inefficient
uh system but there's another space that
actually we struggle a lot more with
which is
how we adapt um concepts
and i'm going to give you just an
example of one that we've had we've had
recently that we're still
um struggling to find the the right
tools
so our son is quite gifted in maths he's
done primary school curriculum and we're
now on to recreational maths and these
are the problems that teach
how you think deeply as a mathematician
than be a sort of a
calculator and i think i'm reasonably
good at math for the phd in computer
science but actually i had no idea
how to adapt this simple problem and
i'll read it out if you want to start
with a number
less than 50 make the longest possible
chain of numbers in which each
subsequent number is a multiple or
factor of the previous number
these numbers up to 100 only once
and in the picture i put next i put the
tool tools that we mainly used for maths
one is an all-in-one board from aph
where you have velcro numbers that you
could
move around and start to put in place
another one is a geometry board that
uses raised line drawings and you can
create raised line drawings
but the challenge here that we found is
like well
even if i can solve this and in a sided
way using my cited pen and paper tools
how can we find a blind mathematician or
two
who can guide us in how non-visual
mathematical thinking works
we know that our son does all these
things in his head but it's very hard to
understand how those relate to we how we
do them as sighted people and the ways
that we do it
but also where are the tools that help
us capture
annotate and spatialize the thinking
process we have tools for
getting the problems we have tools for
communicating the results but most of
what we learn
is that process in between of thinking
how do we capture we annotate we write
we create new things so this particular
problem has a nice online
version where you can create numbers but
that that's not tactile and therefore
it's very hard to do
um mathematics for a blind child without
without it being
tactile and spatial because they have to
rely on on higher order processes that
other children wouldn't need to do
therefore we've been we've been really
stuck with this concept adaptation even
though
all the tools we have are in place
so with that i'd like to
talk a little bit about how some of
these experiences that i've had
have really influenced the research
projects um and the
approaches that we've taken the research
projects and indeed enjoyed many
discussions
with research colleagues who often
wonder why would you take
that approach so i'm going to talk about
project tokyo and project torino so
project tokyo
is a project that provides a
an audio ar experience that helps a
blind child form a mental map
around them using underlying ai
technologies
and we found that this tool we're
starting to use it to support
um social interaction and really
building up those social interaction
skills because many
well well over half of children who are
born blind
exhibit many behaviors that look like
autism because they really struggle
to to build up those quite visual
communication skills
yet many of them are really keen to
interact they just don't know where to
start
so we've been testing out an
intervention we looked at all the
standardized measures for measuring the
effectiveness of
that interaction and much to the
strength of many of my colleagues i
threw a lot of them away
and said this would just not be an
experience for
for the children that are participating
and let me give you one example
one of the very common questions used to
to measure social interaction
um in the neurodiverse population is
do you have a good friend from women
persecution this is a really well
formulated question
um it's short it's been well validated
across many populations
except it forces the child to admit that
actually despite their real desire to
have friends
they don't and what we found is even
when we do ask it they lie
um and then they feel badly about it so
we have to be really careful about
the inclusive measures that we take when
we're building out these technologies
to really understand are we are we
aligned with what
the participants are trying to achieve
and are we measuring that in ways that
might not be just good for external
parties
but for their own engagement and in how
they they see progress
so i've summarized this as the question
is should more accessibility research
focus on
new methods of understanding diverse
populations that can be acquired across
disability communities rather than on
solving
specific problems
now i bring in the example of code
jumper which for me as a researcher was
known as project torino
and in here this for this physical
programming language we did a large
scale evaluation with about 75 children
and we did a number of measures to
measure their um
their their uptake of various computer
science concepts
but we also invited teachers to
highlight the learning that they felt
was most valuable
and what was really interesting is that
without a doubt
the biggest value of the technology was
not to learn to code although that was
achieved in the
vast majority of cases it was having
something that a blind and decided child
could do together without supervision
so even though us as researchers were
thinking about we need to teach these
kids how to code
clearly once we take it out to
participants sometimes what they value
is really really different and maybe we
as researchers need to be
more open to what those communities
might be valuing and i have to say
when this was built and first tested my
son was too little to use it
but now come come a covert environment
where
all of those community activities where
they would normally socialize with many
um bunch of increasingly being schooled
at home like ours is
um are now gone and the parents of
homeschool is like oh we want to leave
them alone let the kids do things
together let them have fun but of course
this is nearly impossible for a blind
child
so this has actually been the one thing
that we've been able to do to enable
social interaction during coven
certainly not one something we planned
but it really starts to push the
boundaries of what is education and
where do we
where do the things that we create
enable those wider set of skills
so i would i would i would put that into
more precisely is education access about
adaptive curriculum or should we be
thinking much more broadly about the
facets of education
that we make accessible
and just for a um final
um a a final example
in formulating a code jumper we also
realized quite quickly that giving
access
to a coding vine was simply not going to
be enough to real learning to take place
for the vast majority of the blind and
low vision children that we'd worked
with in our user studies
we really needed to think through how
concept building was going to take place
across the sp
site spectrum and working from the
literature the emphasis in a lot of the
literature was really that understanding
code execution is critical to
progressing programming skills
this is something that we focus on and
thinking about how do what we deliver
build up this concept of how code is is
executing
and i'll show a video in a minute of
the student who's just really learning
to to connect
the program output with the the
statement that that he's created
and for me again a lot of what we can do
is we can make it accessible but
it becomes much more useful if we can
also think about how we make the
conceptually accessible not just in
terms of accessing
what everybody else is accessing so i'll
play this one video
one two so follow them around three
back to the loop two be quick with your
hands
it's getting ahead of you isn't it three
and in this video as he's following
these pods around as they're reading out
each one is a different number that he's
following around
in this loop we can see at the beginning
he didn't really get it now it's the
case of most children
and then he really starts to connect it
and we found that that's one of the key
moments in which children then can go on
to build
quite complicated um structures in the
code once they're able to connect those
two things
um so it's something we thought quite a
lot about
oops is our video going again so i just
again posed the question how do we make
scalable approaches to concept
adaptation so i'll leave you with those
with those three questions and i hope
um it's been a journey for me as a
parent to bring this into my research
and i hope it may be useful as some of
you
take your research hats on and take this
off uh into the world i've been
really grateful to be here the the
report backs from the feedback session
and just how deep the thinking is in
trying to progress this
forward thanks very much
thank you cecily um i have a couple of
questions for you
um could you say a little bit about
um why microsoft is doing this kind of
research
um it's i mean it's so clearly important
um but some people might perceive a
disconnect between your research and
what they think of when they think of
microsoft which is
typically a company that likes to
provide technology solutions for big
companies um can you say a little bit
about that journey
and you know why why why
you're empowered to do this kind of
thing
sure um so i guess that those journeys
have been
done different journeys but um in the in
the case of
um torino slash co-jumper i think
we as a company are very committed to
computer science education
and when we presented the fact that
there was a
big hole here people went oh yes that's
very true
um but i think it's also been a blessing
to be part of a research institute when
there are so many different disciplines
really rubbing shoulders
side by side um this project really came
about because
we had a lot of kids in we were trying
to do outreach we really wanted to solve
a problem and we realized
we couldn't i mean lo and behold we'd
seem to
have a team over lunch that went well i
can do this and i can do this and i can
do that so
i think partly the environment also
enables such stimulation which is a
lucky place for me to be
um but i think some of the other work
that we've done particularly in the
ai space is that people with
disabilities are often early adopters of
technologies and they're great ways
through an inclusive design approach to
really help us
drive innovation and change that's
inclusive from the beginning
and also helps us think differently for
for the mainstream and we found that
what we build for people with
disabilities often helps us reimagine
experiences that would have we might
otherwise been a little bit stuck in our
ruts for
otherwise great
um okay we have a question from the
audience uh
what's the biggest lesson you've learned
from torino moving forward in your own
work
you sort of hinted at the social aspect
in both code jumper and torino
so i'm wondering if the social side uh
is
if the social side a good driver to
answering some of your thoughts
um i'm just trying to process all the
little bits of that that question so
let me give it a go and see if i haven't
quite gotten it
what is the biggest lesson that we've
learned um
from from torino i don't know if it's
the biggest lesson but
certainly too as you allude to um the
ways that we
integrate students together has become
more and more
on my mind as we've watched how this
happened and we've watched how teachers
are really
um value something that they can do to
enable the social experience of children
the social learning experience they
at least in the blind low vision space a
lot of them use so much equipment that
they have
and they have so much ta support that
they have so
few joint educational experiences
um so perhaps that's not something it's
always something we value from the
beginning that it would work in a
mainstream classroom
it wouldn't be isolated but i don't
think i had put as much emphasis on it
until i really saw how that was working
in process and
the number of teachers that came back to
us in very very different settings from
sort of high resource prep schools to
very low resource
um schools in the the poorer parts of
the uk
they were all using it as a way to
enable
independent interaction with others um
so
it's it's definitely been something that
and just as a personal experience
perhaps the education is essential you
cannot move forward without education
um but at the same time a lot of our
education is how we communicate and
engage with others and if if you don't
have opportunities to learn that
then it will be hard even if you have
the best math skills in the world
to really participate in the world that
that that we live in now and certainly
our children will grow up to live in
great okay we've got one more question
uh and it's a
it's a long one so there's some
questions and some statements in there
so you get to decide which parts of
these of this question you want to
respond to
uh thank you so much for elucidating
some of the most vexing issues in
accessibility research
can you comment about something i
believe your earlier slide suggested but
wasn't highlighted in the
accessibility research statement it
often seems to me
that in education there are concepts of
linearity
in terms of having to master certain
skills first and only then progressing
to the next skill
as a parent of a pwd and speaking to
other parents
i find that the system will not allow
students to approach
certain skills through alternate
pathways as researchers
how might this allow us to reimagine
paths to skill building
among children with disabilities
that is a long question but it's a
really good one and it's one that i
thought a lot about in my my
personal circumstances as well so yes i
i didn't i didn't do the full story of
that first thing we did look into it a
lot more as parents because it was
something that
absolutely um shocked and abhorred us um
but it turns out that blind children
indeed in studies done in the states
take rather different pathways through
um through development
and that those linear pathways don't
really make a lot of sense the one thing
that we found
to be really important and really tricky
in an educational setting
is if the class is moving at a linear
place you don't have a way to be outside
that class that's when kids start to
fall behind because they don't have the
same opportunities to develop those
skills at a different time point
so i think from a research point of view
we can start to think about
how can we and i think computer science
is a great place where this is already
being done
how can we have kids that are learning
on different levels and have that space
for that open learning
that's not in such a completely linear
um path like math tends to be a very
linear path and if you're not in the
bits then it's really hard to fit into
the
the any kind of curriculum unless your
child is completely outside the
curriculum
um whereas computing i feel like there's
much we tend to be more project based
there's a lot more creativity space
and so you can really help push on
people's skills but perhaps those
working in the curriculum space might be
thinking about
how do you enable teachers to to really
be able to push on
different strengths in different
different ways
um this is a as a final comment and from
my
my own experience we have a very gifted
child in maths but he's
his verbal skills are very very um poor
he's fluent in braille he's fluent in
writing but he's
not very fluent in speech at all and so
we were told that he
he wasn't capable at all and it was
actually me sitting down and saying well
we're going to take him at home and i'll
teach him and then i showed that
we could do the whole of the mass
curriculum in nine months and that
really changed their perspective so the
ways that we can open that up for other
kids i think are are critical and i
think computing science is going to be
one of those places we can do that
that's a great great story and a great
example i think we have time for one
more question
uh it was a great keynote exclamation
mark as a budding researcher i'm curious
to
know how can one rethink about
addressing equitable accessibility
within the scope of current research
norms
equitable accessibility um i'm i'm
i mean that could mean several things
but i'm going to guess what that means
and i hope i guess correctly
that means about the the measures that
we that we create
in in what we're doing um how do how do
we do that it's
it's really tough um regardless of where
you are in the in the research chain top
or the bottom
um and we've just found using multiple
measures i think there's a level for me
where
the value just says some things are
simply inappropriate and if we can't
publish something because it's
inappropriate then
i can't subscribe to that research
community in other ways we've tried to
have multiple types of measures so that
we have ones that capture
different people's perspectives from
their perspective and then the trick is
then how do you value that in a research
chain that may not value that in the
same way the participants do
um and it's tricky but i think often
the more we we think about the way we
think about the world
um the more we find ways to to make that
happen i wouldn't say that it's
something that one just
flips a switch and says i can do this
now but it's a it's a continuing journey
that we take and we bring our
communities
along with us great
thank you cecily i'm excited to see
where your research takes you
and thank you for finding time to speak
with us today